the winners had new champions of Dancing
with the Stars our 27 year old model
nyle DiMarco took home the Mirrorball
trophy Tuesday night following a solid
season of high scores and emotional
dances Petey was with the new champs
shortly after their big win I really
want to connect with the audience and
teach him what it really means to be
deaf I really wanted to inspire you know
I was able to bring my upbringing out
through our dance and so we were able to
send out a message through dance we're
really able to achieve that and I'm also
just sad that this has to end
the first week when we work together she
was already starting to learn my
language and about my culture it was
really about learning about each other's
world worlds and I think that message
was really strong and then adorable
Nyles mom Donna joined in our interview
when you saw your son break down tonight
it was such a powerful moment tell me
take me through that and what that was
like when he breaks down it's so easy
for mom to break down you know I just
joined in on the emotion the emotional
journey that he was going through he
really deserves this
you